Speaker 1: Hey, this is I think some of you may
find this interesting. We launched the Pacman
Finance Channel. We announced this a while
ago. And I'll remind you what that is in a
moment. And the comments on this channel are pure
and utter gold, where I am both being called a
socialist communist who has no business talking
about personal finance and also being called a
capitalist who is bad. Like Alex Jones says.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: And for that reason, people aren't
going to watch the channel. So let's back it up
a little bit. About a month and a half ago, we
announced the forthcoming launch of the Pacman
Finance YouTube channel. This will be a channel.
It's not a political channel. It's personal
finance with. Someone who is on the left rather
than like right wing Dave Ramsey. So the way I
like to think about Pacman, Pacman finance is
it's like Dave Ramsey, but not a right wing nut,
not irrationally obsessed with avoiding debt and
not anti-vax. That that's the way I that's the
elevator pitch for pacman finance. And it took us
a while to get this launched and we finally did.
There are currently two videos up, one about
building a logical asset allocation and another
one for how to build an emergency fund and the
right order of operations for one's finances.
Incredibly, after just 24, 48 hours of videos,
we are already at 3750 subscribers to this brand
new channel. It's incredible. I can't thank
people enough. And you can find the channel
at YouTube.com slash Pacman Finance. It's no
frills. Personal Finance How to make a budget.
Why Home Prices and interest
rates move in opposite directions
index funds just basics youtube.com slash Pacman
Finance. But the really interesting thing is I've
been on politics YouTube for a decade and a
half and I know about the kind of toxic nature
of what's on politics. YouTube now being exposed
to finance YouTube. It's absolutely fascinating.
Check out some of these comments that I spotted.
Our friend Tommy Boy showed up and said,
shouldn't you just wait for the government
to give you everything you need to survive?
I don't know when I've ever advocated for that.
And then Tommy Boy adding, This is comical. A
complete socialist talking about asset allocation.
Laughable hypocrisy. If you know anything about me
and my channels, it's that I am not a socialist. I
am a social democrat. That's a well-regulated type
of capitalism. So Tommy Boy is confused. Then we
continue with people with a different perspective.
Sergeant Salty showed up and said, More capitalist
lives. You can get rich too, if you follow this
advice. That's not what I said. You cannot
find a single place where I even imply that.
Sergeant Salty goes on to say. How about instead
of playing into the system, advocate for a new
system that people don't have to struggle to
succeed? And well, come over to my The David
Pakman Show YouTube channel where I advocate for
exactly that type of change. Zephyrus commented I
refuse to watch capitalist content, so some people
won't watch it because it's communist, and some
people won't watch it because it's capitalism.
A couple others sticks. Journey said, Why is a
communist talking about finances? Hmm. And then
Mr. Rembrandt said, Why would a progressive
anti-capitalist start a finance channel? Well,
where are you getting that? I think capitalism
is broken. But I'm not a socialist and I'm not a
communist. And then lastly, this is my favorite.
Jason Crawford asks a really good question. What
actual expertize do you have in personal finance?
That's a fair question. I have an MBA specialized
in financial planning. That's my expertize and
I hope that it is suitable, folks. We've got a
real problem out there. So as a reminder, I will
outline I am an adherent to social democracy.
I'm fine with markets being used to direct
resources in some areas. Broadcast microphones?
Fine. Supply and demand. Put it in the market.
You know, hipster sneakers. Fine. But I want
certain areas out of that. When we talk about
health care, when we talk about education,
there are certain things I don't think should
be subjected to vulture capitalism and the
whims of the market. Everybody should have
a home. Everybody should have health care.
Everybody should have food. We can do these
things. Okay. And as a social Democrat, which is
a well-regulated form of capitalism, I believe
that we should use taxation on the very rich. To
ensure that nobody drops below a certain level,
a certain standard of living. We should be funding
maternity and paternity leave. We should be using
those funds to make sure that we are taking care
of people. The rich can still be rich, but the
richer you get. We're going to take a bigger and
bigger slice to make sure everybody's doing okay.
If you want to call that socialism, you're wrong.
If you want to call that unregulated capitalism,
you're also wrong. We're talking about a regulated
form of capitalism. Okay, so that's the deal. We
don't do politics on the Finance Channel. We
do the politics here. But again, I encourage
you to go to YouTube.com, slash Pacman finance,
be one of the first 5000 subscribers. It's free,
guys. It's completely free. Next video comes
out today. We've got another video coming out
tomorrow. It's an absolutely fantastic thing. We
have a voicemail number and that number is 2192,
David. Now, I'm going to do something
potentially against my better judgment.